这两天打会,突然想起一件事,与也是一年打会
然后我在刷自媒体的时候,看到雷俊老师发了一张图片
这个图片上的话,有一位他的代表证
还要的话,打开的一位书,属上发了一个钢笔
我当然想,因为你作为代表,女肯定是要提起建议和意见的
而且这些意见,女肯定是体验子背的
在这种情况下,你还看一位书,这位书一定是好书
我就把那个图片给他放大了,你这样没有书明了,只是打开的一部分
然后放大了以后,再里面找了一些关键子,然后做一宿书
主要一定要修飘用书书,然后找到了这本书,就是这边
我还能在直播里,跟大家说完,文明先来话,加头起去中国
这本书其实对我的帮助很大
然后我在夺这本书的时候,有一些,比如说他提到了,他在割轮比较大学上学的时候
那么他的本科生完成核心科生
核心科生的要求之一是所有学生,无论什么转叶
都必须吧,电机西方几千年文明的一百多本经典毒物通毒一遍
包括从核马时时让其他直播学习去,中国直学到为一副新,然后起谋怒怒
现在科学科们的所有经典主作
大家都知道我在北大旁行过,就是想看人家到底要学什么,技术学会要学什么
你看,这个时候告诉我们各大,他们的技术学会是什么
然后后面他还有这个书目,然后我就照着这个,几乎把它推业那些书全部独立一遍
那我觉得这是一个很好的学习,电听我的技术
包括后面的话,你看他提到了,对他影响比较深的几本书,比如说枪炮、冰军和鞏皮
比如说西方将族在多久,无情的开始,还有社会性征服地球
这里原除了枪炮冰军钢替我独立,其他没多过
然后看到这儿的话,我就信贝,把那一位书做了个组体的度
包括他后边的时候,我曾经在直播里来演示过,就是我是如何独书的
然后独到其中一张,我从里面抽出了,从离路的方法里面抽出了
寻过的一套方法,知道方法,在这两年被我应用在十万钟
直播里面有,大家可以看到,让你帮我赚了不少钱
我为什么说这个呢?因为前两天的话,我和咱们的老火简,就不爱他们
那天的时候,他说他在去太原和十家庄的时候,他去的一些徒书馆
然后去的一些徒书大杀,对吧,书店发现灯地,除了一些倡修书和主体度
像我们给他重点推荐的一些书,比如说像其他立国电影,想思考快一慢,最累书其实很少
所以各位你想想,如果你是一个偷的请问的人,然后但是你没有走出来
然后你选书都会在这个地方去选书,你会发现你的事件,一定会受限
这种事件受限会影响着,你对未来刀了选择
你不要说,太原了,我是倡资人,有时候回家的时候,我又在书店里做了一圈
说实话,我没有看到什么好书
所以各位我想,作为我们一些小震情年,我建议大家在选书的时候的话,可能不一定有重力当地的徒书馆和书店
也不一定是网红,因为网红,一个是他的认知,你像我个人,我的认识水平,我的道德水平,对吧
所以我建议大家还从一些你做出过程的人,你认可的人,比如说你做生意,你最好看一些企业家
因为有些我们晚上说企业家,都会看过很多企业家,其实就是做生意的,什么是企业家
我建议找到那些真正的做出过程的人,然后他们推荐的书
最好是一些都共同推荐的书,我觉得打开,打开以后找到一本认真的学读,然后你会发现他的一些延展读、包括他的一些推荐读、邀请主席学读,对你的帮助都是非常大的